check this out this is the actual
document from supremecourt.gov
they say state of texas plaintiff versus
the commonwealth of pennsylvania state
of georgia state of michigan
and said it was constant defendants i
don't want to read all of these states
i'm going to read all these states okay
motion for leave to file and brief for
the district of columbia
and the states and territories of
california colorado connecticut delaware
guam hawaii
illinois maine maryland massachusetts
minnesota nevada new jersey new mexico
new york north carolina oregon rhode
island vermont virginia u.s virgin
islands washington
have all been are now partying
in opposition to texas and they
basically just say
that you know they have the right to uh
you know they're asserting their right
to
join the defendants i suppose and issue
a statement on their behalf
so i mean that's about it in terms of
the breaking news but we do have the
direct response
from these states this is from am ny
states respond to texas trumpist's
supreme court lawsuit
seeking to throw out the results of the
u.s election for those that aren't
familiar
with what texas is requesting texas said
that these four states that are listed
as the defendants have
violated the elector's clause the
constitution which states the state
legislatures have the ultimate authority
in who decides you know the elections
and who the electors are
but in these states the courts overruled
in certain circumstances or
the governors implemented new rules
without permission or confirmation from
the legislatures
therefore and for a variety of other
reasons i'm not going to get into the
full breakdown of their lawsuit is
they're basically saying texas
and all 17 states now either supporting
or asking to intervene to join
are saying that the state legislatures
should be the ones who choose the
electors
their republican state legislatures they
would very likely vote for trump or
perhaps they would abstain and if they
did
joe biden would not reach 270 electoral
votes we would likely move to a
contingent election based on house
delegations in which
donald trump would win of course if they
chose their electors
trump would win so these other states
are basically saying no and now we have
half the country lining up against the
other half
arguing about who the next president is
supposed to be i wonder how that will
play out
but the four states had to issue their
response by today and they did
and so am new york says four u.s states
that president donald trump lost in the
november third election on thursday
began to file court papers
opposing a long-shot republican-backed
lawsuit filed by trump supporting texas
attorney general ken paxton
in a lone star state's name at the
supreme court seeking to undo
president-elect joe biden's victory i
like how they say it's just in texas's
name it's like not actually texas doing
it
officials from georgia maine i'm sorry
georgia michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
already have called the lawsuit
which aims to throw out the results a
reckless attack on democracy
the supreme court gave the four states a
3 p.m est deadline to file court papers
pennsylvania was the first to file with
the state's democratic attorney general
josh shapiro saying that
the texas lawsuit was adding a cacophony
of bogus false claims about the election
quote what texas is doing in this
proceeding is to ask this court to
reconsider a massive baseless claims
about problems with the election that
have already been considered and
rejected
by this court and other courts the
lawsuit is supported by trump and 17
other states the republican president
has falsely claimed he won reelection
and has made baseless allegations of
widespread voting fraud state election
officials have said they found
no evidence of such fraud i want to stop
there can i ask you about that
about the lawsuit well just about the
state election officials saying they
found no evidence of such fraud is there
anything you can comment in that regard
because i don't want to
i'm not going to comment i'm going to
question and we're gonna questions what
did they do to find it
what efforts did they make to discover
it because if i close my eyes
and you come here and take my drink and
i don't see you do it i don't have any
evidence you took it because i closed my
eyes right if i'm sitting there drinking
that red bull yeah
but so well that's my question is that
what evidence can they
provide that they applied scrutiny to
what happened
and of course you didn't find anything
if you didn't look for it it's
you know it's not it's rarely is it so
blatant it takes a lot of effort and
you know our own little independent
project we
crowdfunded about six more than now but
uh 580 thousand dollars to sort of fund
it on our own
using very you know tools that were
available to us
why wasn't the state doing this what
what scrutiny did they apply
to i'm actually shocked by a lot of
these court cases
where you know i think in nevada the
trump campaign
presented actual evidence and the court
just said get out of my courtroom they
didn't care
they they didn't even look at what was
given to them and then what we end up
seeing is officials say there was no
evidence there was there was none
i i liken it to you know if i said hey
you guys want to play hide and seek
and then everyone goes and hides and
then like you guys won just like
literally right away
well i couldn't find you it's like you
didn't even get out of your chair oh
well you know i couldn't find you
to what to what degree am i obligated i
don't know if you saw
have you been following the lawsuits at
all from the trump campaign
well i've been involved with some of
them so right right right right so of
course but uh
the ones not involving you know your
project or whatever one of the things
that i just want to say and feel free to
comment on what you can or can't you
know just ignore
but in in pennsylvania a judge ruled
that the election law in pennsylvania
says there has to be observers
and trump's campaign said the observers
weren't allowed near the ballots so how
are they observing
and the judge goes well i don't know the
law doesn't specify distance so as long
as they're in the building
it's good which is clearly not good
faith or to the spirit of the law is
supposed to do
and that's the gist of what we've been
seeing across the board so this whole
thing is freaking me out to be honest
now now that we're seeing all of these
states line up it doesn't matter
like you know i'm gonna put it this way
these 20 states and two territories
that are saying oh we reject this it's
you know these four states have said
it's an attack on democracy it doesn't
even matter what their opinion on this
is
because they're not going to change the
minds of 18 other states
we're at a point now where 18 states
have said definitively biden should not
be president i mean well i should say
effectively said might
not be president or the elector the
constitution has been violated
texas lawsuit says either the
constitution matters
or it's just a parchment sitting in the
national archives
that's a powerful statement with 17
states signing on in support of it some
actually asking to intervene to be
listed as as
plaintiffs in the case in which case
if the supreme court refuses to hear
this then
these 17 states have already asserted
that would that would be a declaration
the constitution is meaningless
and these other states could effectively
say the same thing if the supreme court
can say
no to this election you know uh joe
biden isn't gonna be president because
we've ruled it
they'll they'll argue it's the exact
same thing so that's why i just look at
this and i'm like you know
ultimately it doesn't matter what this
one judge said people have been lining
up
and they know they're right on both
sides they both say they're right i
happen to think one side is more right
than other obviously we all have our
biases
but everyone thinks they're right right
and you know
let's there are many causes to this but
one i think the major contributor
to all of this is how badly the states
manage
elections we've been very lucky because
historically many uh elections are won
by somebody by a pretty good size margin
and what happens is when there's a good
enough margin the mismanagement
um is covered up right it's concealed
but when the margins are close
sometimes that mismanagement and
mismanagement comes in other
you know variety of things it could be
uh creating clerical errors or
preventing
um potential fraud so for example
there's really very little
authentication
done on mail in battle it's essentially
zero and very little authentication done
on
election day bouts we had james o'keefe
show up in dc and take the attorney
general's ballot they gave it to him
said hey i'm the attorney
they used his name was at this this time
around her oh there's a couple cycles
back but
right right yeah yeah so the election
system
has right or wrong created a space for
suspicion
to burn like a wildfire because it's so
badly
managed and here's here's something to
think about right
potholes on the highway right we're kind
of used to the government maybe not
doing the best job of that your mail
getting lost
we're we're kind of a you know okay yeah
postal service this is always a joke
it's a punch line right
or um let's say your medicare not paying
a bill that it should pay
and you have to fight with them we're
all used to that but one thing that i
don't think a democracy can survive is
that kind of uh government uh
those kinds of bad uh management
within the election system or with that
kind of incompetence in the election
system because that's the thing that
allows us to potentially fix all these
other problems so
we're okay with maybe the potholes don't
get fixed or or maybe no
they mismanage a hurricane which is
horrific right but the means we have to
fix those problems
is the election system so but if that is
deemed
broken well then you're stuck then you
can't
fix any problem beyond it i only i
always say if you want someone to be an
anarchist put him at the dmv for a week
and we saw that with the the counting
that that was going on
that showed just wait states can't even
count
so let's address that right the left has
said uh the democrats
the reason why it took longer to count
votes
after election day was because when
people go and vote in person
there they walk in and then someone asks
them their name they're given their
ballot or they go to the machine and
they type in things and they press enter
all of that's done right away when an
absentee vote is being counted they grab
the envelope they look at it
they open it it takes longer to go
through the envelope than it is to have
a person walk and vote and walk out
so the argument is when a person walks
in and votes and walks out it's already
in the tabulation machine
when they're going through absentee
belts doing signature verification it
takes
a bit longer to tabulate that vote and
thus it took a lot longer
but what doesn't make sense in my
opinion is then why they dumped all of
these
batches you know at you know really
early in the morning
at once and it still took more than one
day to do all of this and these batches
came in so
if you look at i think like november 4th
at like one in the morning there were
massive spikes
well if they were counting on election
day as people came in
and they didn't start counting the
ballots until election day why do we
have
you know not the ballots being entered
in at a certain point i guess the
argument is they were barred from doing
it
i still don't think it makes sense as to
how in some circumstances
trump received uh a tiny fraction of of
these these these mail and ballot dumps
that's that's the big question that i
think needs to be answered
right and there was also a legal
argument in pennsylvania before the
election asking the government to count
the votes that were mailed in early
the the government of pennsylvania
argued against that and
republicans yeah yeah and then when we
look at florida i think florida is the
most interesting case because we saw
that
they were caught with their pants down
in 2000 and then they kind of updated
their voting system and
they had the votes in right away all
these other states we don't have one
universal standard
or one kind of voting machine or one
kind of system to count the votes and i
think that's also something to really
think about here i i hear you
but each state runs their own election
exactly and i i can respect that but
what i can't respect is
let me let basically based off what you
just said let me give people an analogy
would you be willing to get on an
airplane if if airlines had a one
percent failure rate
one percent i think the answer answer is
a resounding no well there would be no
airline industry in that scenario
because they'd be paying out lawsuits
every day well because no one would fly
right i mean so new york times reported
in 2012 that the failure rate of mail-in
and absentee voting is between one and
two percent
if i told you there was a one percent
chance that if you mailed in your vote
it would not count
well i think a lot of people probably
don't know whatever i don't care but
that's a pretty
pretty bold bet to make to not having
your voice heard in your election
so when i when i saw that we there was
this and this is a big part of the
lawsuit going
uh going forward with um uh mike kelly
and sean parnell pertaining to the
constitutionality of mainland voting in
pennsylvania
there's a few weird things but when i
saw that all of these changes have been
implemented a year in advance before
covert and then during covet have mass
mail in voting
i mean we saw in paterson new jersey a
whole election was thrown out a judge
actually ordered a new election in
paterson new jersey
because they found bundles of mail-in
votes from a town over
we now have a whistleblower who's come
out and said
they drove a truckload of ballots from
new york to pennsylvania
um i i don't know if that's true you
know witness testimony
is is often unreliable but it is still
evidence admitted in court
so it needs to be considered it needs to
be investigated we need to
look into these things and not just
ignore them and so i i guess i throw it
back to what you said earlier how hard
have any of these people actually looked
into any of the stuff
right right thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you